Світові політики широко обговорюють ініціативу
щодо миротворчої місії ООН на Донбасі
Військовослужбовців цієї місії ще кличуть "блакитними шоломами"
"Блакитні шоломи" доставляють й охороняють гуманітарну допомогу
спостерігають за дотриманням перемир'я
контролюють буферні зони між сторонами конфліктів
Місія, про яку просить Україна, не вестиме військових дій.
Її завдання - підтримувати мир там, де вже є його ознаки.
Перші миротворці ООН почали працювати
на Близькому Сході у 1948 році
Лише бажання певної країни запросити
до себе миротворчий контингент недостатньо.
Рішення надіслати "блакитні шоломи" має ухвалити Рада безпеки ООН
у складі якої п’ять постійних членів
серед яких Росія та Китай, які мають право вето.
З моменту заснування ООН під її егідою провели 71 миротворчу операцію.
Натепер активними є 16 місій.
Здебільшого, в Африці та на Близькому Сході, а також у Косово
на Гаїті та у зоні кашмірського конфлікту між Індією і Пакистаном.
Загалом, за даними ООН, у цих місіях беруть участь
близько ста тисяч військових та поліцейських.
Цього року на миротворчі операції у світі
передбачалося витратити близько 8 мільярдів доларів.
Проте влітку видатки скоротили майже на 600 тисяч доларів.
Урізання могло бути ще масштабнішим
адже під час Генеральної Асамблеї ООН
США, які фінансують майже третину миротворчих місій
вимагали скоротити бюджет до суми
меншої за сім мільярдів доларів.
Але країнам ЄС вдалося домогтися компромісної цифри.
Миротворців ООН часто критикують за неквапливе реагування на кризи
адже їхні відрядження зазвичай тривають не менше півроку.
Їм також закидають низьку ефективність у врегулюванні конфліктів.
Приміром, перша місія ООН - на Близькому Сході - триває вже майже 70 років.
Втім, попри критику, миротворчі сили ООН
залишаються одним із небагатьох доступних світовій спільноті
засобів реагування на міжнародні кризи.